well I takes other people loved him even
those who were suspicious of him at the
start because he was a Catholic found
that he was not trying to advance a
Catholic Church hierarchies agenda he
wasn't trying to put public money into
church schools the way the bush
so-called faith-based initiatives have
done he wasn't sending an ambassador to
the Vatican as though it were a state he
was not blocking the reproductive
freedom for women in fact he was the
first president ironic as the first
Catholic president he was the first
president to support united nations
world population limitation programs so
people got over those early suspicions
and they found that in one program after
another whether it was the Peace Corps
or the space program aiming to go to the
moon or his peaceful resolution of the
crisis in Berlin and above all his
ability to persuade the Soviets to
withdraw their nuclear missiles from
Cuba without the United States firing a
shot yes the I think people realized
that was an unusual presidency and
Kennedy was a new
oh that's hard to say because for me it
hasn't changed at all there have been a
lot of there been a thousand or more
books written about Kennedy some of them
have been scurrilous based upon rumors
about his private life that had almost
no basis of fact and what to what
limited extent they had a basis in fact
is a misconduct and his relations to the
other women paled in comparison to what
we have seen in the White House the
sense so I think that on the whole
people realize and those old enough
remember that the Kennedy White House
years were very special years when
Americans of all races religions ages
parties could respect the United States
could look forward to presidential press
conferences we weren't just reading
about what the Soviet Union was doing we
were interested in reading what the
United States was doing the new Kennedy
initiatives the new I diz that poured
forth a new agency for disarmament in
arms control for example a new attack on
the problems of mental health and mental
retardation in this country so despite
the revisionist books there have also
been a number of other books some of
them have gone overboard the other way
Camelot is a nice story it's a nice myth
and I suppose one might say yes there
was one brief shining moment in our
history and that was the Kennedy
presidency but Camelot is about people
who were well God's we weren't God's we
had a president who
unusually dedicated committed objective
and he appointed a team in the White
House and the cabinet that felt and
acted as he did but we made mistakes the
Bay of Pigs was a huge mistake in there
I'm sure others all of this is going to
be reviewed in some frank detail in my
book my memoirs when they come out in
May